hey guys
it's another delightful day with daisy
so sorry i haven't posted in a little
bit i've been so busy getting settled
back into college it's
august which means back to school
this is my favorite time of year the
perfect time to reinvent yourself
new clothes oh my god
i have literally never been this
hungover are you doing your youtube
thing right now
i gotta take a nap if i have any chance
of making it to class
oh you can just go on the couch i'll be
really quiet i promise
our first project is a do-it-yourself
corkboard flannel calendar every
calendar only uses calendars anymore
everyone just uses their iphone
well uh not everybody has a cell phone
who's watching this anyways what the
[ __ ] do you talk about
you could buy this at target and then
donate the ten dollars you would spend
on this
to like your local homeless shelter
what do you wear on your first day of
school did i just like look into the
sure you want to pick something that's
flattering for your body type
fashionable and shows off how much
hotter you got over the summer
or you could just wear whatever is
comfortable i mean
as long as you're not violating your
school's dress code who cares what
you're wearing
first day at school should be all about
making a statement have you seen my
cheetos
showing how much you've changed over the
summer oh like the summer we discovered
you turn into a bisexual after one drink
charlie you've gained maturity poise and
confidence
just be yourself [ __ ] the haters
she's right be yourself or whatever
screw the haters no daisy
it's the
i haters say that i'll get flagged for
parental advisory
thanks so much for watching guys comment
below with what you want to see next
week
yeah like if this gets five
likes i'll tell you guys about daisy's
summer secret
i have no idea what she could be talking
about hashtag back to school 2k15
and as always subscribe do you seriously
do that every time
holy [ __ ] we gotta work on a new sign
off
i mean that was awful comment below if
you want a new sign off
all right